well and more exciting news a lucky
lottery winner in Wisconsin is waking up
very rich in fact three-quarters of a
billion dollars richer this morning the
ticket with the Powerball numbers you
see on the screen won the third largest
jackpot in US history it's an estimated
768 million four hundred thousand
dollars now the lump sum payout would
total about four hundred and seventy
seven million dollars the store that
sold the winning ticket is in New Berlin
just west of Milwaukee Niki Vitesse is
here with more good morning Niki
good morning happy news finally the odds
to win are astronomical one and over 292
million but the lucky winner beat them
and is now set to become one of the most
famous people in Wisconsin he or she
cannot stay anonymous
according to Wisconsin law and the state
lottery says it will proactively publish
its winners on its Facebook page and
website the ticket holder will have 180
days to claim the prize Wisconsin
actually cycles most of its lottery
revenue back into its economy thirty
percent of all ticket sales go to
property tax credits for its homeowners
to get an idea of how much money it is
with the lump sum the winner could buy
the most expensive private island up for
sale in the world and still have enough
left for a few private jets to take them
there someone's having a very blue pool
Thank You Nicky